Director Gerard Johnstone employed the "less is
more" adage while reshooting his
eagerly anticipated robot-horror
flick M3GAN. What he ended up with was
even more disturbing than the original.
Is it too early to proclaim the
movie of the year? In any case,
M3GAN has already accrued a ton of buzz
on the strength of its trailer alone. The
artificially intelligent title character
— with her blank stare and TikTok-ready
dance moves – is the clear frontrunner
for horror's cultiest new villain.
M3GAN stars Allison Williams in her first
Blumhouse feature since 2017's Get Out. Williams
plays Gemma, a robotics engineering whiz who takes
in her orphaned niece Cady, when her sister and
brother-in-law tragically die in a car accident.
Gemma provides a companion for her traumatized
niece in the form of M3GAN, or Model 3 Generative
Android. When the childlike droid becomes
overprotective of Cady, she becomes infinitely
more violent than Gemma ever anticipated.
"Are you listening to me, Brandon?"
While some fans are worried that the film's PG-13
rating will tamp down the scares, director Gerard
Johnstone insists that the teen-friendly
rating made M3GAN even more disturbing.
In retooling M3GAN to achieve a PG-13 rating,
Johnstone leaned into the idea that the power
of suggestion can be terrifying. For Johnstone,
reshooting certain scenes and emphasizing cutaways
and off-camera violence was even more disturbing
than straightforward gore. Johnstone said in
an interview with Total Film and GamesRadar+:
Johnstone recalled reshooting a specific
scene involving the scary dog next door.
The end of the scene occurs off-camera, leaving
the dog's fate entirely to the viewer's
imagination. Johnstone told the outlet:
Other off-camera scares are surely
in store for those who accidentally
cross M3GAN's path. Giving M3GAN a PG-13
rating may not have been the original plan,
but it didn't take much to walk the movie back
from an R rating. Johnstone said in the interview:
It makes sense to court teen audiences,
given the ages and sensibilities of the
main characters. Johnstone continued,
Furthermore, PG-13 horror films
aren't without precedent, and one,
in particular, was a lodestar for Johnstone.
The director told Total Film and GamesRadar+:
Indeed, Sam Raimi's supernatural horror
film has a devoted cult following,
despite the lower rating. Roger Ebert
even called Drag Me to Hell "macabre,
over-the-top, fun, funny, silly and loud
and bombastic" — characteristics it achieved
without an excess of gore or adult-only
themes. Other beloved horror movies,
including A Quiet Place, The Ring, and The
Sixth Sense are all rated PG-13 as well.
"I see dead people."
Jason Blum also has no qualms about the PG-13
stamp. The producer told The Hollywood Reporter: